قصه حلوى البقلاوه والزلابيه مع المائده
الرمضانيه قديمه جدا لكنها قد تختلف من
صانع الى اخر وباحجام مختلفه ايضا عرفت
اربيل بوفره المكسرات وهي ماده اساسيه في
صنع البقلاوه وربما يكون السبب في حشو
اكثر من طبقه بمكسرات الجوز والفستق ليميز
طعمها بشكل لافت عن بقيه مناطق العراق
عجينه
وجوز وبعدين عجينه وبعدين جوز وبعدين
عجينه يعني
بداخلها
والدهن ماله يختلف ويا الغير بقلاوه
والهيل دارسين
همينا القياسات يختلف وحجم الجوز يختلف
البقلاوه العاديه
[موسيقى]
العم ابو خالد وهو مختص بصناعه الحلوى في
اربيل يشرح طرق صناعته حلو ى شهر رمضان
الذي يعتبر موسم الطلب للحلويات كافه من
بينها البقلاوه والزلابيه وكذلك العوامات
وزنود الست هذه البقلاوه
عندنا ندخلها بعد ما نفتح العجين
نعطيه مراحل ثلاثه بالبدايه وبعدين
المرحله الاخيره اللي هي الفتح بهذا الكبر
نفتحها نبدا نقطعها على قد الصينيه ومن ثم
ننقل هذا الورق
اربع خمس ورقات تكون بالاسفل بعدين نعطيها
القشطه مالتها او الحشو مالها ومن ثم
نعطيها الطبقات الباقيه تتشابه المواد
الاوليه في صناعه مختلف اصناف الحلوى
ومنها البقلاوه والزلابيه الا ان السر
المهنه في صناعتها يختلف من صانع الى اخر
وكلما طال عمر ذلك سر لدى صاحبه طال وقت
ابواب الرزق المفتوحه حسب اعتقادهم احمد
الحمداني العربيه اربيل لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات